you're not gonna win
at some point you will like this video
it doesn't matter if it's now
it doesn't matter if it's then it
doesn't matter if you come back in a
month
a year ten years on the eve of youtube's
destruction you will come back here
and eventually you will like this video
some of you have already lost i know
my charm is infectious my smile is just
so captivating it's undeniable the
likability of this video
i know some of you may feel like a loser
for liking this video but
whenever you fail it's not an if it's a
when
write down the comments what time you
failed at
given that the posting of this video is
the start time
and the end of time is as much time as
you have
let's see how long you last
until you like this video because i'm a
very patient man
i got nothing but time i'm in a hotel
all by myself up in canada
sitting around in an empty room staring
at the walls
you think i don't know patience you
think i don't know discipline
you think i haven't ordered my thoughts
so rigorously
that nothing could penetrate the prison
that is my mind no
yes whatever the answer was that makes
sense that one
and the only answer that makes sense to
you is liking this video
oh i see you saying in the comments
below
you won't get me but i will i already
have
youtube videos when they're posted they
stretch on into the ether
till the end of time which is
coincidentally whenever youtube gets
deleted but until the end of time
my message stands and in the great
quantum realm of reality
all things are possible there's another
universe where you've already liked this
video
why run counter to your destiny why not
just go down below it's so tempting
the thumbs up it's right down there
waiting for you eager to invite you into
its
bosom of its warm embrace you know what
i mean
you do don't deny it don't say you don't
know what i mean you know what i mean
you know exactly what i mean and you
know exactly why i mean what i mean
so don't deny what i mean and don't deny
what you mean to yourself and like this
video
in your time there's no rush
we don't need to take things faster than
they need to be
you know i spent a lot of time getting
this room ready just for this video
i was waiting to make this video happen
for you
so that you could understand yourself
because that's what it's all about
that's what it's all about is
understanding yourself
and i understand myself and i understand
you
just the normal canada
greeting of the ending of the day it's
wonderful isn't it it's a beautiful
place up here in canada
i don't see much of it considering that
my hotel window looks out in another
building
so i don't really see very much
got my setup here on a chair i'm sitting
on a coffee table there was no table i
have a chair
so we all make do with what we have you
know we don't question our lot in life
we don't we don't try to change things
we know where we're going we know
exactly where we're going
and where you're going is back to this
video even if you leave
you know it's going to crop up it's
going to crop up in your recommendeds
and youtube's going to be like
hey ho you didn't finish this video
maybe you would like to give it another
shot huh
why don't you come back and give it
another watch and you will because it'll
auto play some night
some night when you're drifting off to
sleep it'll auto play
and in your sleepy state you won't even
know what you're doing
when your hand unconsciously reaches out
and clicks the like button so don't
fight it
don't resist or do make it more
interesting
you know i'm all about that some people
they like at the beginning
some people they like at the end but you
you're different you're special i
appreciate that and i recognize that i
see the potential within you to stand
out from the crowd
you're unique a unique butterfly
and you like everybody else will press
the like button
in your own unique way you don't follow
the crowd
no you lead you're a leader
everyone else is a follower except for
you you're gonna show them the way
you're special you're above them
you're beyond them you like it in your
time
i'm amazed i'm amazed by your tenacity
by your innovation by your imagination
by your captivating handsomeness and or
beauty
it's really indescribable so thank you
for giving me the chance to
even be here with you whatever time this
is that you're watching this video first
second third fourth fifth sixth seventh
eighth
ninth tenth 11th 12th 13th 14th 15th
16th 17th 18th
19th whatever whatever make it a yearly
thing
make it an annual thing you know the
only shame is that you can only like
this video once
but you will eventually
take things slow you know no rush no
rush on anything
just like me in this hotel no rush here
time kind of goes really slowly much
like the internet speed
very very slow
probably gonna take me like like a day
to upload this video
you know it's very slow so if that has
taught me anything it's taught me
uh a lesson in patience patience
waiting durations how slow a second
actually is which
is surprisingly very slow when you watch
when you watch a clock when you watch it
and you just you know i had to rip the
uh i had to rip the second hand off of
this clock
because it was going so slow and i was
like how can it go so slow so
now i just watch this uh this big hand
here and i see the uh
imperceptible motions in it as it
crosses through the day
eventually you'll like this video i know
i know but you know
i uh i don't want to seem like i'm
pressuring anybody you know i don't want
to seem like i'm pressuring anybody i
just
i know i know human nature i am a human
after all we all know this
and i know human emotion and i know
human willpower and i know the
tendencies of human peer pressure which
is not what i'm doing
not what i'm doing at all i would never
i would never do that
to my fellow humans so for those of you
who have failed already it's okay
join the losers in the comments and
write the time when you failed
just go ahead and write the date or like
the universal time code or whatever it
is with like the date and the second and
the minute and like the nanosecond
you know i should look at nanoseconds
that would make time seem like it's just
flying by
you know flying by i am a whopping three
days into my 14-day quarantine
and time would just be surging past it
would be like it was over in no time
that might be uh it might be too scary
you know i don't want time to go by too
quickly
i wouldn't want that i want to savor the
moments i really want to savor the
moments just like i want us to savor
these moments together
the moments that we have here you know
we're never going to get them back
well you are because this might be your
fifth time watching this hello again
hi i are you good to see you but anyway
you know for me it's the first time
here you know it feels like it's not the
first time you know i keep waking up in
the same room and i'm just like wow
here again i'm not allowed to leave i
love this wall in that corner i've seen
that one oh man the
molding on the the ceiling is lovely i
got these cool mirrors here
that's nice
and i have you guys with me because i
have a connection to the world through
the power of the internet we are
connected across
time and space in any moment you can
always come back here and remember
there's a like button waiting for you
and who knows maybe in the future
by the time you wait maybe the wait will
be worth it and like youtube will put in
a feature where where like if you click
the like button it'll give you like
a magical present that'll shoot out in
confetti from your computer screen
or your mobile device you know whatever
it is the future is really amazing
i can't wait to see it feels like
wherever i am you know time is just like
not at all time is no you know
everywhere else time is yes but here
time no
can't wait for that i can't wait for
that i must wait for that i am waiting
for that but
you know when that future is here
that's great hey see it moved i knew i
wasn't watching at that time but it
moved
that was great man that's cool i can't
wait till it hits this corner here
that's a really exciting time for me
um it's like uh
which way is up
time for you to like this video you know
now's a good time i'm gonna offer
everyone
a uh a a a subscribe once get one
subscription free
event if you like the button then
subscribe you'll get double your amount
of subscriptions
and that's like extra value you know you
don't even have to pay for that you
don't even have to pay for anything it's
all free actually
all you have to do is sit through ads or
whatever or my sponsored content from my
valuable sponsors of which i have many
because i am a well-respected youtuber
who makes high-quality content
so why don't you just take your time no
rush on anything
and uh you know you can look forward to
a lot of cool stuff on this channel but
maybe you want to save those likes that
you were going to put on those videos
for this video right here and maybe you
know you might actually get a little bit
of a bonus
surprise you know what i mean i don't
know i don't want to make any promises
here that i can't keep but you know i
want to i want to allude to things that
might be a possibility in the future you
know
maybe maybe maybe you know
yeah whatever you know it could happen
come on like the video
it's actually starting to get concerning
that you haven't usually this whole like
asking thing works you know youtube kind
of pushes out this idea that like
oh man you gotta like you gotta give a
call to action and stuff and i'm like i
don't wanna do a call to action i
to have a manipulation exercise i want
to really get into the minds of people
and usually this stuff kind of works by
now or at least youtube said that it
would work
maybe i misread the note on what a call
to action actually
meant anyway how are you i haven't even
asked
i haven't even asked how you are hey how
are you
you having a good day you having a great
day you having the best day possible you
know what could make it better
there's a like button down below i
imagine you've clicked it by now i
imagine that like the majority of you
have clicked it by now
and you know i actually feel bad i feel
bad for calling it losing
clicking the like button is actually
winning it you win the game
you win that youtube video anytime that
you like a youtube video you won
you won celebrate boom boom you win
hell yeah congratulations i'm proud of
you
i will be proud of you at the moment
that you click the like button i
actually have a feedback loop
i have something attached to my heart
it's like a mini defibrillator but i
turn down the voltage so it won't kill
me
it just hurts a lot so every time you
like it i get a little jolt
and it's a little concerning that i
haven't gotten any jolts yet
you know um i think
what it must be is the internet here so
bad that i'm not getting like the signal
and then when i go to bed at night it'll
all hit me at once you know like
everyone's like i'll just
remember but you know for now i'm just
gonna
assume that's true because the
alternative would mean that no one
liked this video
[Music]
i mean i'd be fine if that were the case
i would be fine
you you know i i'm
gonna go call and i i can't answer right
now i have to
you know record this you know i don't
get many calls here because i'm all
alone by myself so me declining that
for you guys is pretty important and i
would assume that you guys would
understand
the sacrifice that that meant and
therefore hopefully you know
relationships are built on reciprocity
you could like the video
for me you know to make my life a little
brighter
yeah that's another like you lost oh my
god of course it's losing jesus
what are you even thinking oh you lost
well you felt bad about that
you felt bad i decline calls all the
time i don't give a [ __ ]
i don't want to talk to them i love
being by myself
in a room just taking in all the
environment the walls you know
it's kind of nice see something new
every day when you really look at things
when you really look deep at things you
see something new every day
and there is so much to see there's so
much to see out there and there's no
more for you to see you already like the
video comment down when you did it and
get out of here no no no take backseas
it doesn't matter you clicked it come on
get out of here
doesn't matter doesn't matter you
clicked it get out of here uh
you'll get them next time maybe probably
not you know what i mean
oh man all right high five everyone high
five on the thumbs up button if you
thought that was awesome and you didn't
fall for that trick club boom got ya
there's a few more oh man i'm winning
every day
i'm winning every day every day that i'm
here alone in the hotel room i'm just
winning i
feel like the winning spirit is flowing
through me you know
it's tiring i guess winning oh yeah by
the way there's seagulls here so
lexie and cut that bird out leap all
this out bleep by everything that i'm
talking about right now shut the [ __ ] up
bleep out anything that's happening over
there shut the [ __ ] up
keep it incognito you can't tell anybody
about this
[ __ ] off [ __ ] off
okay good glad all right we got that
settled don't worry about that you don't
need to know about what that was
you don't need to know about anything
it's just the neighbors
i yell at them all the time we
we have conversations i wasn't trying to
say that we [ __ ]
that's not what i was going for i don't
want anyone to think i was saying we we
[ __ ] it was gonna be we fight but then i
changed it to conversation
we don't fight shut the [ __ ] up
anyway guys the like button
is there for your convenience so that
you can indicate to youtube
exactly what you enjoy i'm about to
reveal you
what the like button actually does
because some people don't seem to
understand
you click a button to show youtube that
you
want this youtuber to succeed above
everyone else and if you like their
video you are locked out from
ever having an effect on a like of any
other youtuber ever
you like one your first like on your
account is the only like that counts
make it this one or else i will be
deleted from youtube when the youtube
hunger games start
it starts yesterday and the likes count
now
that was a trick the thing about youtube
is lies
get you subs first lesson for those of
you who are new to the channel thank you
for coming by
i am a master youtuber because i am able
to get these uh
these likes going you know i really am
the likes really translate to something
tangible that definitely actually has an
effect on me
if this is your first time watching this
if this is your first time through this
thank you thank you for watching this
and get ready
for a lot more really cool stuff coming
from
my hotel room where i will
have tons of stuff for you of
entertaining quality
which is what i do i have a standard of
quality for the videos that i make
which is why so many people like my
videos it is reflected
in the count of videos that i have that
are liked
you can't find a single one that's not
has one like
you can't find it you can look you won't
find it you won't find a one
i have so many likes
have i been at all convincing
this if you weren't convinced the first
time around here's your opportunity to
hit the replay button
okay cool